I think within the last year or so for Max Holloway or like when Max Holloway's
face goes up on the screen,
people,
people go nuts cause they know he throws down.
Yeah,
I think it was the Ortega fight.
I really think that Ortega fight made him a superstar.
I really do.
Although one's definitely helped them.
The bad tabak although ass weapons and then Art Ortega,
one thing that was different,
those or Tayga had a big following or Tayga was the young beautiful lion lion
with fantastic Jujitsu's handsome guy.
Cool.
Smooth talker.
Looks like a champion.
Yep.
Fucking everybody up.
So he had a lot of fans coming in there and they went to war.
They went to war and Max came out on top.
And I think Max,
a lot of those pm because they were so cool with each other during,
before and after,
people loved it to Max is he loses better than anyone on the fucking planet.
We'll loses or wins.
He just goes,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm just going to get better.
He doesn't lose a lot.
He doesn't know.
I mean he lost to Connor.
He lost very first ever,
you know,
but I 20 years old.
But I also think Max is because we've always said,
I think both of us had been an agreement where if a guy is cutting a ton of
weight and kill himself,
go to the next weight class.
I've always said that,
whether it was a Darren till,
whether you know,
uh,
Chris Weidman,
Luke Rockhold,
Jon Jones,
like,
dude,
go up a weight class dominate.
And then this is kind of the first time we've seen a guy where it's like,
hmm,
it's not that easy because Mac taller we went up,
but you could see the power wasn't there.
Like he might've,
he and he did,
he landed more than a dozen play.
But when Dustin had landed it,
you could see that it fucking counted.
Dustin is big dude.
He's big [inaudible] 45 [inaudible] 45 and really struggled there.
Um,
but at 55,
he's found a spot and you look at him,
he almost looks like a welterweight.
I mean,
he's big.
He looks like Tyron Woodley size and he cuts a shitload of weight and Max
Hallway in that fight.
Just looked like they didn't look like the same.
No,
just play like fucking well and you've got to give credit to pour your too
because if you look at the two of them,
like after the fight there was a big difference between the amount of damage,
the poor Atlanta,
big difference.
He was hitting him with big shots and it wasn't just big shots,
it was shots period.
He was hitting him with really clean,
well time shots with great head movement,
great movement about that knee dude.
Everything split open his head,
everything.
He did everything great.
I mean he really,
that was a coming out party for Dustin Poirier in a lot of ways for the common
fan.
Well yeah.
Well the people that knew him from the gauge you fight knew him from the Eddie
Alvarez fight.
They knew that man,
he beat these two really good guys.
But Max Holloway might be one of the best pound for pound fighters in the world
and I think is I think is to Max hallways the greatest one 45 of all time.
Yes.
I think he's a damn good.
50 fiver but,
but 55 could be tough for Max.
Well this is a great example of what we've always said about the differences
between the size of people.
And this is,
it's,
it's first of all,
I mean,
all credit to,
uh,
Dustin Poirier cause he put on a phenomenal performance.
He got,
you know,
he got tested in that fight.
He came through.
Let me see.
We've talked about in the post fight interview that he got hurt in the third
round.
He came through and just super impressive.
Think about as striking a pennys Anthony Pettis,
world champion [inaudible] world champion,
Eddie Alvarez,
world champion,
Max Holloway,
World Champ Pedis one though.
Wasn't that an injury?
I feel like Penn has got injured and they stopped the fight.
Like did he break his hand?
Is that what happened?
No.
Feel like the pet,
it's one was an injury.
He had the issues with Eddie Alvarez.
Right.
Which was a no contest.
Yeah,
I think,
well there was one fight where Dustin Poirier no.
Yeah,
I think,
I think that was it.
There was one fight with Pettis were Pez broke his hand at Duke.
Roufus stopped the fight.
Remember that Ferguson was the 21st Tony Ferguson.
You're right.
But I think that was a great frown.
Maybe it was an injury.
Oh,
is a rib member.
I was a right.
That's right.
Dustin got on top of him and hurt his wrist.
Right,
but still look at plays.
Wins,
man.
Yeah.
Well that's a weird one too.
Right?
It's cause like what was that rib injury from it pouring a body shot.
What was that from?
Or is it from the takedown?
Like what was it?
Something happened.
I don't remember.
That's right.
But he's more like a Tko.
Yeah.
You look at portrays his list,
man.
The guy's who's fighting,
who's lost too.
It's so impressive and poor is the guy.
Same thing with when Michael Bisbing one I always root for those guys,
those guys who have been around forever and they fight the best of the best.
They might lose one or two here,
but they've been around for so long.
You just hope there's a title at the end of their career.
Yeah.
You just hope and it sometimes doesn't look like it's going to happen.
Then when it does happen,
I just,
I'm just so happy for this.
Such a good guy to Dustin poetry guy.
He's a great guy.
He's smart.
He's ambitious.
Seal Vons.
Favorite fighter.
Works hard to how lyricists that scene,
those two guys together.
That was hilarious.
Called them the right.
Both went the same whole school.
How about Theo was yelling instructions.
I'm going to,
I seem to mind king of steam.
I'm going to roast the shit out of him.
Did you yell at take off down.
I went.
What?
What is happening right now?
Why does this happen?
Yeah.
Shouting instructions.
UFC provides me with a headphone.
I was hoping you'd,
you had to turn around.
I'm like,
dude,
what are you doing?
I'd love to,
you know,
he's the best.
Yeah,
just character.
Unique kid.
He was so happy.
He was so happy me made him bet.
Well,
I just bet because obviously him and you thought,
um,
that I thought did you think was going to be a great fight?
I thought Max at 55 if everything was and carry with them,
I thought Max would probably get it done by noon,
was going to be good fight.
I was just spending field because Theo is boys with Dustin from the same area,
so it's just a friendly bet.
I would never bet against us in boy,
look at these fools.
Hilarious.
That's amazing.
How about a few fields?
Never been in a fight before and he texted me halfway through goes,
dude,
I can't believe you did this shit.
I go,
maybe a little respect now around king the staying right.
You're a little fucking respect,
bro.
Yeah.
He was looking at it as a complete outsider is no idea.
I told him,
I said,
it's super intense,
man.
You're seeing for the best fighters on planet earth.